you can debate the specifics but in
general most Americans seem pretty happy
that Congress was finally able to pass
an aid package that benefits ordinary
people as well as companies in fact the
bill is so generous it even gives aid to
millions of non American citizens as
long as they're here legally but for one
member of Congress that's not enough in
fact the bill isn't generous in her view
it's an insult Alexandria Acacio Cortes
the dumbest most unhappy member of
Congress maybe the one person out of 435
would have no influence on anything and
yet still does has now denounced the
stimulus bill because it leaves one
group out illegal aliens you can't make
it up is she really working for the RNC
secretly probably but in her view people
with no legal right to be here people
who are filling American jobs crowding
American hospitals lowering American
wages during a brutal unemployment
crisis good people perhaps but not
Americans people violating our laws for
aoc these people deserve eight just like
American citizens the ones who are
hurting and out of work so what
percentage of Americans support that
idea we haven't seen polling on it but
right now you'd think the number would
be right around zero it was foolish to
think that during our strongest period
our richest time America could provide
free everything to the rest of the world
but to demand the same thing when the
economy is on the edge of collapse when
tens of millions of American citizens
are in danger that's not dumb that's low
thing for your own country obviously